here's the first story Elon musk's
Twitter I like how they call it Elon
musk's Twitter reinstates rep Marjorie
Taylor green so this is from the past
couple of hours of course Donald Trump
has been has been reinstated don't know
if he's going to come back project
Veritas is back James Lindsay is back
who else is back I'm seeing everybody
come back is back Andrew Tate is back
anybody else Marjory Taylor green don't
know Elon Musk is just you you think
he's he's going through a list and then
just like looking at why they were bad
about okay we'll unban them and like
who's this and like unban them but the
graveyard of suspended accounts is just
so large that there's no way to know
who's never going to come back
well we're waiting for Sargon Carl
Benjamin to be unbanned yeah I was just
thinking of him did he get did he get on
pan I feel like I saw that today or
people were just calling for it it
Blends together yeah I think Michael
malice tweeted out that it should be
unbanned okay yeah yeah there's a bunch
of people Rick had a lot still uh he's
still banned Carrie wedler band uh Dr
Malone doctor
um McCullough anti-media free thought
project somebody we could keep going we
could do a whole show just by naming all
the people that have been disappeared
off of the face of the internet I know
Milo said he wouldn't come back to the
platform but so did Donald Trump
tweeting but come on my letter is this
Milo has to come back I really want him
to yeah what do you think Darren who who
needs to come back and do you think
Trump will come back oh there are a lot
of people that need to come back Trump
he desperately wants to and Elon
understands that hence the recent tweets
that he sent out expressing the uh the
temptation to which Trump is yet to give
in but
he's just got to he just finds he needs
to find the right opportunity to do so
they say they're potential legal
complications
um given his fiduciary responsibilities
to truth social so that has to be worked
out and as you know the system will use
any opportunity can get to file another
case against Trump and it looks like
there are already three or four in the
work so
um It's Complicated business with Trump
he wants to and if we subscribe to the
um uh modification of Occam's razor that
Elon propounded on Twitter namely that
the most entertaining outcome is the
most likely I think we can all expect
Trump to be on there and many more
colorful figures to come we need to we
need to pull this meme from Elon Musk he
tweeted and lead us not into into
temptation and it is the meme of the
woman showing her private parts to the
Monk and the monk is refusing to look
the monk of course is Donald Trump and
the woman's derriere is Twitter so uh
very good there's another one where it's
Lois Griffin all disheveled looking
looking over at a bottle of prescription
pills and uh uh I just got to point out
there's a woman she blocked me though
she she quoted this and then wrote this
is rape culture a billionaire promoting
rape culture on his platform and then I
was just like men not wanting to have
sex with women who want to is rape now I
guess and then she blocked me for it so
no but it's actually true the the rape
is actually him not giving in to the
dead
well if anything she's assaulting him
the the race she's you know he's just
mine he's praying right he's minding his
own business and then she comes along
and she pulls up her dress and just like
starts looking at him you know this
guy's minding his own business
he's not being a Sim maybe you should be
praised no but not maybe that's what
she's right
ships okay
this is a serious deal here so uh
obviously you know you're portraying
Donald Trump doing the right thing here
right maybe maybe that's what she meant
maybe I misunderstood maybe she was
saying the woman was raping the man
yeah that nowadays it's a little bit
Elon Musk was trying to imply that he
was trying to seduce Trump but it's been
nearly three days and and Trump still
has the ability to tweet but yet hasn't
done it he can't and I mean he he can't
because of uh Financial interests with
truth social so we should explain it in
kind of basic form here Trump is having
the opportunity to make a lot of money
with truth social rather than of course
have a voice on Twitter he did make a
couple statements a couple months ago
saying that he wouldn't return to
Twitter even if Elon Musk would buy it
uh will he return I think he has to if
he's running if he's going to be running
a successful presidential campaign
because there's no other way to get out
in front to get your message across but
most importantly also protect yourself
against the incoming attacks and
Slanders and all the fake news media
bullcrap along with the doj indictments
there's no better way to protect
yourself than in the court of public day
uh and and that of course means using
Twitter will he use a court of public
day something I just made up right now
uh Court of public light
board of public opinion thank you thank
you you think Elon should buy truth
social then for no more than it's worth
and then he technically wins I got the
solution
literally seriously okay Donald Trump
tweets a sentence
with a link to truth social which
contains the paragraph So that way he's
still getting his idea on Twitter he's
maximizing his audience but he's
actually helping truth Social Grow
th I think that's the best thing to do
because more competition in the space is
good and if he can build if he can build
another Community then we never have to
worry about monopolistic censorship from
what I read uh truth social has a six
hour exclusivity window uh and therefore
Trump must post on this is what I read
it could be wrong uh but Trump trump
post on Truth social then six hours
later he could post the same thing on
another social media platform and
there's exceptions to the rule like
fundraising uh so he can post on Twitter
According to some of the mainstream
media sources out there and they're
they're kind of larger agreement with
truth social but at the end of the day I
mean is he prioritizing money in his
platform over this platform and will
this kind of outcome be in his benefit I
don't think it will are you saying truth
social has the uh possibility of
becoming profitable because I don't see
that
oh definitely yeah it could be
profitable do any of us at this table
use it no well I have one and I will say
I don't use it but there's a lot of
engagement on it it is significant it's
elon's probably trying to steal back
that uh uh engagement of the users that
went over to it yeah I think Elon saw
this as a business opportunity he
probably was just like look how many
people they've kicked off the platform
that they're losing money because
they're bad at business I can come in
post some spicy memes everyone will
start screaming and spitting and yelling
they'll all come back and then we'll
we'll you know go public again in a few
years right and there's been a massive
influx into Twitter since Trump's count
was re reinstated a massive number
um so look look at this
this tweet from Donald Trump from 2011.
I feel sorry for Rosie's new partner in
love whose parents are devastated at the
thought of their daughter being with
Rosie a true loser this this history was
wiped from existence by by Vijaya God
and Dorsey and with Elon Musk coming in
we get the whole archive it's a
veritable library of Alexandra accordion
back there was one life is sweets
there's literally
were being sold on Amazon wow that's
amazing yeah I love all of Trump's old
tweets telling Robert Pattinson to break
up with Kristen Stewart I'm looking him
up now because I just love him so much
it's amazing see here's the issue why
don't even even this Trump isn't on
Truth social
true no it's not the true social posts
are like paragraphs about like Maga
stuff come on Donald Trump call somebody
a horse face right
we need to we need to bring back the
snarky one liners this was hilarious man
I can't believe it this stuff's 11 years
ago yeah Trump was sitting there on his
golden toilet just insulting people on
his phone and we all thought it was
funny yeah like three in the morning
assaulting people but like remember when
he posted his like taco bowl yeah that's
great like that's so wholesome
there's nothing so lighthearted on the
app is when that went up yeah bring back
Twitter Trump I guess man all the crazy
stuff on Trump's
Twitter thread we have to go back in
time and look at all the archives
letting me word search anything he's
tweeted right now you know there have
been glitches on on Twitter that I've
noticed mostly that you'll try and load
a tweet and then it'll say
um the suite is unavailable or the
replies are upside down
upside down yeah so like they usually
are below a tweet but they're above a
tweet and they're in a
non-conlinear the number of employees
yeah yeah well it's happening a lot more
for me they appear above the Tweet yeah
yeah wait yes you have to scroll up and
then it's confusing and then it's all
messed up and hey look just
combatulations if Twitter implodes and
is wiped off the face of the Earth I'll
take it as a win too like you've got
this platform that is clearly biased
against anyone who poses The
Establishment namely conservatives
because the Trump you know as Trump came
in but even anti-war people are getting
banned so if Elon Musk tries to fix it
it's a good thing if he unbans people
it's a good thing this could be you guys
ever hear hear that stuff is that
focused he's a terrorist oh no have you
guys ever ever he's outside have you
ever heard the story stories about how
like someone on their deathbed all of a
sudden will become like lucid and
energized and they'll sit up and start
talking and be totally normal and you'll
be like oh they're getting healthy and
then they just die you guys ever hear
that
like people who are like dying and like
laying on their bed will be will just
one day get up and be like I'm feeling
better I'd like to see my family and
then the family will come in they'll all
talk and laugh and then also the person
was like like croak like it's the body
mustering of the last bit of energy to
make your final you know you know finish
your business and say your goodbyes
maybe this is what's happening Elon Musk
comes in we're all like yay we feel
invigorated again like it's 2015 2016
and then like the replies flip over and
and the words start getting jumbled the
tweets stop appearing and then it's gone
but it definitely doesn't feel like
2016. and then the microchip goes inside
of your head without you even noticing
it without your consent and then boom
you're connected to the new WeChat of
the United States without your consent
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time